I want to present to you
the Bridgetown Initiative.
It’s a pragmatic, ambitious plan
to save the world
that's been gaining surprising traction.
I’m going to start with a “who,”
move to the “what” and “where” we are.
I came late to climate.
I wasn't a skeptic.
I'm an economist.
We believe that if we don't value
something well enough,
we tend to overconsume it.
I believe that.
I just wasn't seized by a compulsion
to do something about it myself
until September 18, 2017.
I was sitting in the
departure lounge of JFK,
waiting to go home
to Bridgetown, Barbados,
nursing a coffee,
and my phone buzzes.
And it's Mia Amor Mottley,
college friend and then-leader
of the opposition of Barbados.
“Go to Dominica now,” she says.
Our neighboring island.
"They've just been smashed
by Hurricane Maria.
They need all the help they can get.
Time for you to step into the shoes
of that previous generation
of influential development economists.
Just like your dad."
She's compassionate, super smart,
and obviously a good politician
because I am on a UN
relief plane the next day,
doing a hairpin turn to land
on the emergency airstrip in Dominica.
The pilot's last mission
was dodging missiles in Syria,
so I'm feeling fairly safe.
I have my head wedged against the window
transfixed of what's below.
A hurricane can release the energy
of 10,000 nuclear bombs.
And below me is a nuclear wasteland.
Pointing up towards me
are a million thin white sticks.
Takes me a moment to realize they’re trees
stripped bare of all branches,
leaves and bark.
When we land,
I’m assaulted by the smell
of burning and decomposition.
And something else it takes me
a while longer to work out.
I'm on a tropical island,
normally teeming with birds
and insects and color,
in deathly, monochrome silence.
The birds have gone.
The land is emptied.
Later, Dominica's Prime Minister
Roosevelt Skerrit says,
"Dominicans have lost
everything money can buy
in four hours."
The government's job was
to make them feel that what was left
was the valuable stuff --
community, family, hope --
and to help them repair.
Because if despair set in,
then a bad, bad situation would get worse.
Early on I work out that the way
to get recovery funds flowing
is to make Dominica matter to the world.
So Dominica declares they will rebuild
as the world's first
climate-resilient nation.
They dust themselves off,
stand tall and resolute,
and invite the world's experts in.
Turns out, the Dominicans
have the real insights.
We made a list of all
the things they had to do
in the immediate aftermath of the disaster
and asked what would they have to do now
so they wouldn't have to do that
next time around.
And the answers kept on heading higher.
Energy and health resilient systems.
National and regional food security
and then the global,
because there's no real alternative
to halting climate change.
And that's why the world's biggest plan,
the Bridgetown Initiative,
comes partly from the world's
smallest countries.
And it actually makes
even more sense to that,
because tropical places
are where temperatures,
droughts and sea levels will rise
to their highest, most extreme levels.
We are the canaries in the mine
and we can see there's no point
gasping for air for ourselves.
We have to save the mine.
And we can also see
what’s getting in the way,
because whilst most people believe
climate change is here
and happening and urgent,
they also believe someone else
should be doing more about it.
Rich countries are electrifying,
shifting, reducing,
so much so that the majority
of greenhouse gas emissions,
63 percent and climbing,
are now coming from developing countries.
There is now no pathway
to avoid the world's destabilizing
planetary systems
without the green transformation
of developing countries.
The rich say to the poor,
"You need to ban emissions, tax carbon,
shift into renewables
and get with the program."
But that would slow the growth
of developing countries.
They'd have to borrow a lot
at very high interest rates
to invest in the new,
decommission the old,
find new jobs for old
coal miners and more.
And why should they?
The rich cause global warming.
They're responsible for 70 percent
of the stock of greenhouse gases
in the atmosphere
for using up 60 percent
of the world's carbon budget.
You can't scoff 60 percent of the cake
and then say afterwards,
"Well, we all need to cut back now."
(Laughter)
Don't cement inequality.
(Applause)
"Don't cement inequality,"
the poor say, "Send aid."
The problem is that all
of the aid in the world
will not fund one twelfth
of the green transformation
in developing countries.
And rich-country governments
are not getting elected
to send money to foreigners.
They're getting elected
to deport foreigners.
So we're stuck, staring at each other,
pointing fingers whilst the world burns.
I figured that the way
to break this impasse
is if we stop only looking at ourselves
and make the cost of resilience so cheap,
the flow of finance
after a disaster so immediate,
the green transformation
of developing countries so profitable,
that we turn reluctance into a scramble.
There's no extra time.
We're on countdown.
And that is the essence
of the Bridgetown Initiative.
During COVID and the global
financial crisis,
rich countries purchased
24 trillion dollars
of bonds to pump their economy.
If instead, they'd purchased
24 trillion dollars of bonds
that finance renewable energies,
we would have had the same economic impact
and be halfway to halting
climate change already.
And we would have reduced
our inflationary dependence
on oil and coal,
all within 12 years.
The power of what we can do
when it matters to us is unlimited.
So here's the financing plan
that does not rely on the altruism
of financiers and insurers,
is not based on some unproven tech
and does not skirt around our common
but different responsibilities.
Picture three buckets.
Small, medium and large.
The smallest is actually
the hardest to fund.
It's all of those things that don't
generate any savings or profits.
It's rebuilding the homes
of low-income families
that are being washed away
by climate events.
It's rebuilding, recovering
their livelihoods,
their clinics, their schools.
And climate change, remember,
is the increasing certainty
of rising losses.
It's uninsurable.
So we need new sources of public finance.
We need new emission taxes
on oil and coal and methane.
At the Mottley-Macron Summit
in June in Paris,
we made some progress towards taxing
emissions on the shipping industry.
We need more.
And we need a small
financial transaction tax,
like the one you don't even realize
you're paying today,
that covers the cost of the US SEC.
And energy and finance consumption
is slanted to the rich.
The second bucket is for those things
that don't generate revenues
but generate immediate savings.
If I invest a dollar of borrowed
money on stronger seawalls,
more muscular flood defenses,
more resilient health systems,
I save several dollars.
So we need the international
multilateral development banks,
like the World Bank,
to lend three times more
on the Sustainable Development Goals
and to make that debt cheap
by making it longer and lower-cost.
They can get halfway there
by using the resources they already have.
They're very conservative.
And the other half,
they need rich countries to put in
a little bit more capital.
Now, some people criticize me for saying,
why are you going for cheap
loans rather than grants?
And I say, if you found a trillion dollars
stuffed behind the sofa, then OK.
But grants will never be enough.
And so let's focus our grants
on those things
that can't be funded any other way
because there's no savings and profits.
The final bucket,
the biggest bucket, is for those things
for which there is a revenue attached.
But before I go to that,
on the second bucket at Paris,
at the Motley-Macron Summit,
we got a commitment of an extra
20 billion dollars of lending a year,
a start.
The third bucket, the biggest, revenue.
Solar farms, wind turbines,
they make money whilst
reducing greenhouse gases.
In the rich countries,
81 percent of that is funded
by the private sector.
If we want developing countries
to move faster than rich countries do,
then we want those investors
to go to the developing world.
They don't today
because of the high cost
of guaranteeing their returns
against the fluctuation of currencies.
However, history shows
that an international agency
capitalized by rich countries
that takes a diversified view
across time and countries
can lower the cost
without losing money ...
by enough to unblock
the flow of investments.
And a small group of countries have agreed
to move on a pilot this year.
Three buckets: small one for costs,
middle one for savings,
big one for revenues.
There are a couple of things we also need
to do that doesn't cost money.
We need Barbados-style pause clauses
in all debt instruments.
When a disaster hits, you suspend --
your interest payments and debt repayments
are suspended for two years,
added back on to later
when you can afford it.
It will release billions of dollars
and reshape the financial system.
And as Prime Minister Mottley says,
if we want these institutions
that were set up in the colonial era,
if we want to trust them
to save the world,
then the people they serve
cannot be invisible in the halls of power.
(Applause)
So the impasse is cracking.
I got on that plane to Dominica
because of my dad.
Not because of his profession,
but because he was a dad.
I remember asking him once,
when I was being asked
to join an unpopular cause
that was going to hurt my career,
and I was half hoping he would say,
"No, son, that's silly."
Instead, he said gently,
"Avi, you've got to be
a player in this life."
So here I am.
Please join us.
(Applause)